what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
june the 14th a beautiful day to be
alive the joint
is brought to you by blue chew listen
let me tell you something
whether you're young whether you're old
you always want your dick to be tip top
magoo
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
at a fraction of the cost
you could take at any time day and night
the process
is simple as can be you ready for this
you sign up at bluetooth.com
you talk to one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved which takes like
20 minutes you receive your prescription
within days
the best part is it's all online nobody
knows nothing
no visits to the doctor's office no
[__] stared downs from a doctor
no awkward conversations no going to the
pharmacy now she knows you gotta [__]
the dick
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
not even the mailman knows bluetooth
tablets are made in the u.s
of a and prepared and shipped directly
it's way cheaper than a pharmacy and let
me tell you something
i popped a couple of blue tubes and
they're [__] tremendous you
understand me
after the hamstring [__] tad i had a
few problems with my heart on
but now it's okay the blood's not
focused in my leg
my dicks tip top magoo but i'm 58
so for that extra little added you know
what i'm saying
you pop a pill even if you're 20 and you
got the hardest dick in the world
give blue chew a try you want women
walking away from your house limping
right or wrong
you want them to say don't mess with
that [__] he gave me dick for
two hours straight
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew is for you and blue chew could
help and they got a special deal for you
right now
try bluetooth for free what are you
talking about joey
free with promo code joey that's it just
pay five dollars for the shipping
that's blueshield.com b capital b i
know most people say uppercase [__] that
i'm an old man capital b
l u e capital c h e
w dot com promo code joey to receive
your first month free and as always i
want to thank blue chew for sponsoring
the joint
and i love blue chew i think they're a
great product it's safe and like i said
to you
we could all use a little bit of help
you know what i'm saying you get that
little [__]
uh pill you're popping you go over the
house
you don't tell it till afterwards so you
don't get confused you follow the saints
here
go to bluetooth.com and the code joey
and receive your first month for free
okay
and now it's time to get the
[__] party started
it's the moment we've all been waiting
for it's monday morning [__]
candles lit let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 14th
of june holy [__] the weeks are [__]
flying let me tell you something i had a
great week last week a great little
breakthrough week last week uh
i talked to mike we had a i told mike to
start watching me a little better and
uh it was for nothing you know
sometimes in life you get stuck i've
been stuck the last 10 months and you
guys noticed it
i know it i feel it uh just every once
in a while
you go through [__] the last 10 months
i've been feeling
how i felt after i got my divorce
when i got divorced in 91 there was a
year after my divorce that
i just wasn't right i wasn't stable um
mentally stable like i was having fun
and i was doing comedy and all that
stuff
but i wasn't really feeling like myself
and
that's what's been going on lately and i
thought it was a big [__] problem
you know i thought it was a bigger
problem than what i was i mean
how can somebody do something for 30
years and not want to do it
i thought that uh i've been acting a
little differently
since i moved here i've been a little
bit more um
cautious a little bit less
less movement i felt in la i was getting
pulled
from every direction and i wanted that
to change
for me to be a little help happier and
healthier
and that's what i've been focusing on
you know uh i got friends that call me
like hey what are you doing today at 3
this guy wants to meet you that's those
days are done like those days are done i
i'm too busy with the [__] kids and
you know my own world and what the [__]
is going on
and it's it's but it's so funny how it's
taken
people nine or ten months to realize
i'm not the same guy i used to be
especially since i moved here
because i put more focus into what i
needed to
but one of the things that brought me
back and we're going to go through this
we're going to keep hearing about this
because i can't believe that i preach it
to you
and sometimes i forget to [__] use it
you know mike you journal yeah
okay it's really weird i journal and i
like journaling and i've pushed it on
you people for [__] 30 years
you know it helped me to get off the
coke it helped me when i
when i was locked up it helped me in a
lot of ways and i didn't even know what
i was doing
i didn't people called it a diary when i
was growing up everybody had a diary
with a [__] lock on it
you know don't look at my diary i don't
want to read your [__]
i don't want to read nobody's [__] you
know but
that's the thing it used to have a lock
on it with a little key
not listen a [__] four-year-old could
pop it open that lock don't stop nothing
from nobody
it's like when people have a safe in
their house guys like me would just pick
it up and take it to go you know what
i'm saying
that's great you got to safe you better
[__] staple it down weld it into the
wall
i can't open it but i'll take that
[__] safe to go we'll take it
in the car we did it a couple times
i i was gonna drop a name on you but i
don't want to drop no names
i don't want to recur any felonies and
[__] like that he'll probably watch the
podcast and call me back and go yeah
we took a safe one time we opened it up
there was number quarters in there
and we ended up throwing in a [__]
lake unbelievable the thing must have
weighed 800 pounds
quarters are heavy dog i picked that
[__] up
i picked it up and i could feel my balls
blowing up i
dropped it and i said [__] it i'm just
gonna push it down the stairs
and i started pushing the safe down the
stairs and it was rolling
it hit the bottom floor and then i had
to get the safe to the back door on the
bottom
so i pushed the safe down and it banged
into the [__] door now i had to go
down there
and [__] body [__] push the
[__] safe to open up the door
and i open up the door and i go into the
[__] thing to see if my buddy's out
there
and my buddy's out there with his trunk
open but there's a cop car
sitting there they're just sitting there
watching for traffic and i'm like holy
[__] the alarm didn't go off
i'm like what the [__] happened we get
the [__] safe i get them
i tell them drive around with the cops
there the cops stayed right on the
[__] corner i go drive around
i go you gotta help me with the safe it
weighs [__] 10 000 pounds
he gets out the guys the guy's street
name was
the lip we pick up
we pick up the [__] safe we put in
the trunk of the car we go back to his
house
i'm banging this [__] thing he's got
a welding [__] thing
we finally bust the thing open we're
expecting to see 50 [__] g's
and so help me god it was a bag of
chains
this [__] big and maybe eight dollars
in singles you don't know what that does
to your confidence level
if you think i was struggling the last
couple of weeks you should have seen the
look on my face that night
and then we had to take the [__] safe
carry it pick it back into the [__]
thing the kid cut his hand he had to go
get eight stitches
because when he welted he [__] left
the metal up and he [__] sliced his
hand
so we had a [__] throw the safe in
the water he had a bandage on his hand
and then we drove to the hospital had to
sit there like a [__] [__] for
three hours while he got like [__] 18
stitches in his hand
my point is with the [__] diaries you
cannot
you know you want to write stuff in
there and you hope that
nobody bumps into that stuff what i
usually do is after a couple years i
just take them and burn them
or shred them you know my wife i'll tell
my wife to shred them you know but
i was struggling until about
six days ago and i changed my journaling
routine
what i did was
i added a steve simone trick you open up
with
gratitude what are the [__] never mind
what you ain't got
never mind what your pals got never mind
what bert christ has got
never mind what you know whitney
cummings got
what do you have that you're grateful
for five things
he told me the same in the shower a
bunch of us do that
me ari five things you're grateful for
every day when you wake up in the
morning you wash your [__]
when you're in that shower say em out
loud
not in your head you have to say them
out loud five things i'm grateful for
my daughter my wife the second chance
god gave me
the house and my career how it ended up
this could have [__] ended up worse
the lawnmower man wants to come down a
4.0 monday morning [__] he shows
up with landscape
you know what i'm saying whatever the
[__] landscape landscape
so you say five things that you're
grateful for every day
every [__] day steve simone taught me
that years ago
and you get up and you say in the shower
and it's great
and lately when i'm driving in the car
instead of [__] listening to the
radio i just talked to myself in the car
making believe i'm talking to somebody
else you know what i'm saying and i'll
say
what am i grateful for today i'm
grateful that i'm driving i'm grateful
that i have a job i'm great
you know all these things because
sometimes we [__] forget
what really is going on who get you know
you didn't get that job at the dental
office who gives a [__]
you got a beautiful wife you got a
beautiful daughter you know
you know things are happening so we
forget that [__] we overlook it and
that's what's been going on with me
lately
i've been focusing on why don't i want
to do this
instead of the things that i am doing
you know we're writing a book with
putting a weed strain out
hopefully today me and mike shoot a
[__] little video for an nft
you know there's always there's always
something to do
you know i don't want to do stand-up yet
you know i see all these people putting
up all these [__]
schedules and stuff like that i'll be
out don't worry about it
i got a time and a place and a plan i
got a summer that i want to [__]
enjoy
you know what i'm saying all these
schedules are going up you're seeing all
these schedules going up
and i got a summer i got to enjoy i got
guns and roses coming august 5th to
[__] met life
they're coming back september 11th and
12th i think
my wife is getting tickets for pnc for
somebody else steely dan
is there with their little jazz trio i
mean guys we got a great [__] summer
here i'm not
if you think i want to tell my wife and
a bunch of people at 6 30 i got to leave
to go do a show in morris plains get the
[__] out of here i'm [__]
partying with them i'm doing everything
i don't give a [__]
so what i took with the journal was this
week i started instead of just writing
you know monday july what
what's today's dating in the 14th
whatever monday june 14th
i open up with five things that i'm
grateful for today
you know the second chance i got the
[__]
just everything getting out of la not
going to austin
you guys see what happened over the
[__] weekend i woke up to that on
saturday [__] morning you know
i got a call an anonymous call last week
from a dear friend
telling me that he just don't like
austin he can't you know
it was it was not for him that the
homeless is out of control
the traffic is out of control and that
downtown was very violent
that uh somebody had thrown a bottle at
him
and uh i knew lee was going
[__] down there and i came home and i
called that [__] right away and
i told him i said lee
you gotta do me a big [__] favor and
he's like what
and i'm like
i said let me tell you something i go do
you need this austin money because i
just mail it to you
i go i don't care if you're going to
austin but i want you to [__] be
careful
i've spoken to a couple people that have
played the club down there
and they say the walkway from the hotel
to that club is a bit [__] dangerous
he had to walk around
and the second night he had to tell the
owner to drive him
and lee you know you guys know i care
about lee he's
you know i don't want him to get beat up
you know what i'm saying i don't want
him to get mugged or nothing like that
so i called him and i [__] told him
listen buddy
it's the hotel and the club and you and
the agostino you got you know his
strength in numbers
if it's that type of situation you know
what i'm saying i don't know but because
i heard that downtown
austin was really bad so i called him
and i called [__] the agostino and i
told them both
hey you guys got to watch each other's
backs tomorrow
i can't lose lee and i can't lose the
agostino be careful
do your sets don't make any unwanted
movements
[__] i told lee to call me when he
got down and tell me what he thinks
and he said that the traffic was [__]
horrific and that the homeless people
were everywhere it looks like a
a little model of l.a and
that was it you know i was happy he had
a show i didn't want to bother him
friday night so i didn't call him back
i told him don't call me back after the
show go have a beer go have a good time
[__] saturday morning i wake up to my
wife waking me up at 7 30
that there's been a shooting in [__]
austin dog
guys i know you're not going to believe
this i [__] levitated off that bed
the only reason why i didn't hit the
ceiling was because i had my sleep max
have me a mask
[__] rope you think i'm [__]
kidding you dog i [__]
levitated off that [__] bed you know
that's my little [__] brother i took
that mask off and i ran downstairs
and sure enough there was a text from
lee saying hey buddy i'm fine i know
you're going to
read this i don't want you to worry
about it
i called him up i asked him what
happened he kind of you know
told me what he had heard whatever it
was one shooter
you know so that was you know every day
has been something
it was a very [__] exciting week last
week i mean uh
monday we had practice uh
tuesday i don't know what the [__]
happened wednesday
we had a drive for a playoff game we
drove all the way down at guys
you guys know i lived in seattle you
guys know i lived in colorado
so when i tell you this i tell you this
from the heart i saw
a rainstorm on [__] wednesday
that was so [__] intense and so
beautiful
at the same time i almost [__] died
it started with just a couple drops
and all of a sudden we were on the
playing field we were not even on the
playing field we were in the grass
talking
because they said that the game got
pushed back 20 minutes in case it was
going to rain so we were just standing
there
and all of a sudden we felt a couple
[__] things come down and all of a
sudden it just
opened up and it started [__] hailing
june whatever june 8th 9th whatever the
[__] wednesday was
it's [__] hailing we're in we weren't
even in our car we my friend that's a
detective
he has a big truck we all because that
was the closest truck to us
we all jumped in there we sat in that
car in that rainstorm
from 5 to 6 to 6 35
watching that [__] rainstorm coming
down thunder everywhere ba-boom
but boom everybody was [__] freaking
out nobody was driving
everybody stayed in place because there
was nobody i saw a [__] drive
a parking lot get three inches of water
within [__] a minute in that 35
minutes
me and my wife had to run to that car
listen she had an umbrella
and i had an umbrella over mercy and we
both
were [__] drenched my wife's panties
were [__] wet her bra
my shirt everything we had to [__]
come home and then we were freezing in
the [__] car because it was colder
tremendous i shot a movie on friday in
new york city
[__] tremendous if you see the smile
on my face it's because i forgot
i forgot about how much fun that kind of
[__] was
it was [__] sensational and it was
inside the studio because
when you shoot in the studio it's great
we shot
on the [__] midtown manhattan
in front of a [__] in front of
people there was barricades there was
people yelling
it was [__] tremendous to get the
vibe from the city
it was let me tell you something i had
to drive
to queens on wednesday for covert test
even though i got the vaccine the whole
thing they didn't give a [__] then i had
to go back to queens on thursday
for wardrobe and then i had a shoot
in the city on friday no big deal i'm
not i was [__] i was very fortunate to
get a job
i put the audition on tape like a month
ago i'd forgotten all about it
i went over f friday it looked cloudy
like it looked like it was going to rain
on the way up i'm like [__]
i'm not going to be able to shoot this
now i got to come back on monday or
they're going to reschedule for another
[__] day and i got this hat
because i hate having [__] hanging over
your head i like booking that type of
[__] you book wednesday you shoot friday
that's the way it's supposed to be
once they start telling you august 18th
you're like god damn it
i gotta wait till long it's [__] 18th
so i went over there friday
i was a little you know you hear [__]
about the city so you're a little
apprehensive you're hearing that they're
hidden people on the head with sticks or
whatever
i haven't been over the city too much
since i've been back you know twice just
like
three times this week but uh i drove
down 42nd street it was [__]
tremendous all closed i saw all the
places
i used to go that's completely [__]
different i mean it's completely
different i don't know what the [__]
they did down there
there's no sex world on the corner no
more you know i used to sit
i i drove down 42nd street and you hit
night
and you you got port authority there
right across the street used to be sex
world but on that [__] corner
is a tremendous they used to be a
tremendous little arab dude who made sad
bread hot dogs
with the rat tail on and everything
still tremendous dirty water dogs
and he's got little steaks on a stick
little cat meat on the stick let me tell
you something listen
usually i wouldn't eat that [__] that
[__] gives you the meat
with a piece of bread on top and you put
some frank's hot sauce on that
[__]
oh lordy i couldn't wait to catch a bus
in new york when i lived here in the
[__] 90s and 80s i couldn't wait to
get a bus
because the first thing i do i would
take my hunger right to that
[__] i'd open up with like four
sab red hot dogs
and then i'd open up with like two or
three steaks on a stick so you guys
wonder how i got the 418
and two cans of [__] coke and then i
would go to harlem and get weed and eat
cuban food up and haul them all
and then come back to port authority and
smoke another [__] and eat some more
steak on a stick
that guy wasn't there no more and across
the street from there used to be a thing
called
sex world years later jamie masada put
the laugh factory on top of sex world
really yeah it was disgusting i never
performed in there but
i used that last night oh it lasted like
[__] eight months not too long
i sat on that [__] corner
eating steak on a stick and hot dogs and
i would watch
all the hasidic jews at seven in the
morning go in there
like tons tons and sometimes i would
no you don't get rubbed on what you do
you go into sex world
and what you do is it's disgusting
listen you have to be a disgusting
person to go into this thing and this it
just wasn't
it was everybody i was disgusted i mean
i've been going to sex world since i was
like 13.
they have like condoms and dildos and
[__] no it's like going to a [__]
uh going to uh jenkinson's you know what
jenkins
is in point pleasant it's like a an
arcade
so it's an arcade for sex okay this is
this is an arcade i swear to god sex
world was [__]
a disgusting arcade for sex it was
basically
you walk in and there's like three guys
with those aprons on
with tokens in their pockets right and
you go off to them you give them like a
10 and they give you a handful of
disgusting tokens
disgusting tokens okay forget bitcoin
this is sperm coin this i don't know
what valley this has rusty pennies
and then they have a circle okay
it's like a an oval room
with different boots okay different
boots
all around and
when you approach him you'll see a guy
walk out of that booth
and nobody makes eye contact they look
down
they would walk out looking at the floor
and they would walk out
and you would look like what the [__] is
wrong with that guy until you opened the
door
and looked on the floor and there's a
ball of sperm on the [__] floor
and then the guy goes excuse me a little
mexican guy would go excuse me
and he would come in with a mop with
like disgusting water
and just throw it on the sperm clean it
up
put it back in the buckle and go you're
ready
okay thank you and you'd go in and they
had they had two of these they had
the one with the glass okay so you had a
glass
and then and you could just look in and
it would be so
like as a kid as a 12 and 13 year old
the first time we did it was great
because we would go
and at first a window would open
and it would either be a a a skanky
[__] white chick
you know i just shot up heroin because
that's what they do they're hookers
and then they go there to make extra
money at six in the morning
so what you do is the window opens up
and you put tokens and and you put your
dollar by the window and she comes over
and you can either suck a tit or finger
you can get as much as you want
for whatever until she leaves it was
disgusting you had to be 12 to [__]
even enjoy that thing
you know you stick your hand in you're
trying to finger her you
i still remember running out of there
and like all our friends getting
together going what'd you get
i got a tit i got to smell my hand oh
[__] it's
[__] disgusting when you're 13 but
you're a kid one time we played hooky
one time a bunch of us played hooky in
the eighth grade and we went over there
and we took this kid with us that just
transferred his name was paris
great [__] kid we went over there i
told this story on the church we went
over there
we got some tokens there was sex world
and then if you went on 42nd street
there was other little copycat once
there was a place that sold ids
you could buy ids for you know to go to
clubs and [__] like that
they had all that [__] there i'm talking
about the 70s
to see it now and what was going on then
it's two different [__] years like
and now with what's going on in the city
that disney store they got on 40 seconds
let me close it
let's go back to sex world not that i
would go there but that's what people
really [__] wanted anyway
the other ones had the windows that
opened but you had to keep putting
tokens in that [__] oh they were
closed
and that was the time i went in with the
kid and he was sucking a tit
and he forgot to put things on and the
window locked on his thing
and they had to call the [__] we left
them you know us we [__] ran outside
they called an ambulance and they got
this thing and
the kid's a [__] state trooper now in
san diego that's why i didn't go to san
diego that much
because after that thing caught him in
the neck they transferred him his mom
transferred them out of mckinley i i
don't know why
but we were going to sex with all these
[__] kids and it was disgusting then
but we could look in you know as a kid
when you're 13 you don't know what the
[__] you're looking at you think you
know about sex
you have no idea so what it would be it
would be a room you go in there there's
a window there was three different
styles
you either had the chick that went from
window to window and you could suck at
it
and finger her for a dollar a dollar
fifty whatever the [__] he had changed
as long as you were putting tokens in a
lot of times they come up to you you're
negotiating
and the window will go down and you're
like [__] and you put the token in and
all of a sudden you're like working on
tokens like you're like
what can i get real quick i don't know
you know they weren't gonna suck your
dick or not like that it was you feeling
that ted or you
trying to finger them so you had that
style or whatever then you had the style
that was just a glass
and they put that pit on the glass and
you just sit there
and rub one out and then [__] it's
disgusting
your [__] snake your sneakers would
stick to the floor
like you would hear your sneakers when
you were in this [__] place just
disgusting
but then they had the ones where it was
just people having sex
that's like the 3d that was like when
they went
deep so it started with the people
having sex
it was just like some [__]
white dude like a bent dick
it's just you have no idea this when you
leave that you didn't feel too good
you know what i'm saying when you were
13 you're like oh
like it was [__] disgusting he would
have like a curved dick
and the chick would be [__] you could
see the the
track mark track marks on the arms and
he would be [__] her and you would
just sit there
but you could see your friends in the
little windows
yeah they're all in little windows and
you can tell who's jerking off you know
what i'm saying
so you got to keep your [__] straight
like you know
if you [__] yeah you kind of like
jerk off cappuccino
from this position over here like just
make believe like nothing was going on
but they had those type of [__] sex
shows where they would just [__] in the
middle
but then they had the special ones when
they would [__] in the middle
and they had chicks rotating and the
windows would open and you could finger
them and stuff like that and
you know you could oh you when the
window opened
smell it oh like a bit
oh and then when you walk the [__] out
here comes
johnny mop with the hot boiling water on
the [__] sperm
and you look at that bucket i remember
one day i just looked at that bucket and
i'm like god
damn how many kids are in that [__]
bucket this
there's a busload of kids in that
[__] bucket just
just but it has changed they really [__]
out listen guys i haven't lived here in
23 [__] years
when i came to new york to do shows what
do you think i [__] sightseed i was a
[__] tourist
i got family to see and [__] like that
so i never got to see
so i for three days in a row i drove
down 42nd street and the memories that
came back to me
were [__] you know and that's why
like
i was trying to figure out what was
wrong with me you know
the last couple weeks with the
journaling
and it came to two things it really did
come to two things
i came back to a place
that had so much pain
involved when i was growing up you guys
forget
i found my mother on the floor
on a hit of acid
do you have any idea what that does to
your mind
i do because i lived through it i didn't
[__]
gank myself even though i wanted to
[__] die
i didn't i kept it together and
the best i could i knew i was a drug
addict and i did a bunch of bad things
but when i came back here you know when
i would come back to new jersey to do
comedy shows
it was three days i didn't have a chance
to think about
what when what was going on or what
happened or what didn't happen
i would be focused on comedy and about
seeing my friends and going out to
dinner and stuff like that
this move made me it made me look into
the [__] closet guys
it made me look into the closet and look
at those skeletons
and remember i had
i have a skeleton closet like everybody
else a main one
but i have new jersey has its own little
skeleton closet do you know what i'm
saying like i have a big skeleton closet
like the one behind mike is sitting
and then i got a little closet over
there that's my new jersey secret closet
that's my skeletons in that closet
but those skeletons hurt there's a lot
of pain involved with those skeletons
so i figured that out through
what is [__] wrong with me what is
affecting me what is making me
feel not like joey like wild man joey
you know uh and listen guys
i've been smoking the last couple nights
i've been smoking i roll
i go on my little porch at night i get
my little [__] tea
and i smoke and it's putting me to sleep
the plan i had is working
i slept great last night i slept great
the night before
guess what i called mike there then when
i say to you less is more
love is blind didn't i say that to the
other day i said
less is [__] more mike i found that
out last night it's working
i stopped putting all that [__]
whatever in there
i gave you some abx's he sent us a shout
out to abx
the best [__] edible in the business
i don't give a [__] what anybody has to
say
the best you understand me and how do i
know
because i've one million served how
about that
when it comes to abx i got the [__]
look at this and this is the these are
the good ones
oh yeah this is the one mike don't like
the 200. i like the 200s but those ones
hit me
i don't know why this one hit the 100s
hit mike mike told me that
that the hundreds hit him harder in the
200s and i started experimenting with
and i think mike's got a [__] point
they sent me the 25 milligrams sleepy
time
oh really yeah and i dropped one of
those last night
with the teeth that's it no more
syringes
how to feel did you feel anything it
feels good
i'm still i man
the [__] dreams the skeletons are
coming out
of the dreams man that listen i
i enjoyed this writing it down in the
morning [__] yeah i i listen
i enjoyed this and part of my routine
listen that thing that
rogan those guys are doing sober october
i got to admit it to you guys i made a
mistake by not doing it
and i'm very sorry the bigger the man
the bigger the mistake
you just cop to it you know me i tell
you guys i
i [__] up i didn't want to be a part
of it and now i'm going to do one
every year i'm not it's not gonna be
october
i'm gonna know when i need it i'm gonna
know
last night yesterday i went over to do
you know friday i went over to do that
movie
i'm the type of guy when i go on a set i
bring edibles
i bring reefer just in case you no
because there's people there and they
help you
they help you tie in your shirt they
tell you that you have lent on your
thing they
they come to you they're trying to make
you look good
so from i always take edibles and
always bring weed on sets with me as
soon as i go to the makeup trail and i
see those girls they start talking
i i base what they're listening to the
music they're listening to and i listen
to the conversation
and right away i'll go you ladies want
to get high and the room will stop
they're like what are you talking about
i brought the weed that [__] jerry
lewis gives the kids
when they stop [__] raising money
yeah and they look at me like what are
you talking
about and it the same was yesterday uh
friday same thing on friday
i went in the makeup chair boom boom
boom she was cool as [__]
then she gave me the hair they cut my
hair a little bit they trimmed it up a
little bit
they gave me this little meringue
[__] hairdo
and i told lane you ladies are getting
like yeah let me tell you something
i just told the one girl just walked me
back to the trailer
and she was like fine she was cooler
than [__] she was married to another
girls
she was part of the lgbt community cool
as [__] she goes i'll walk you
we walked back to the trailer i opened
up that [__] bag and i just hand i
go put out your hand she goes what she
went like this i go
she goes that's too much give it to the
[__] girls
go give it to the other girls if you
don't want and then i gave them that
those powdered edibles
yeah the pure wine how did they work for
you
they're all right i put two of them in a
water bottle and this is yeah
they need i need like i think you need
more yeah that's what it was
because i did like three of them but i
gave it to my buddies and they enjoyed
it they said they got a night there's a
new thing called piranha
it comes in a box i'm sorry i i used
them
you know i gave them away yesterday or
friday whatever the [__]
and uh you just rip them put them in
like this much of water
you shake them and i'll get some more
and i'll turn you guys on to them i
think they're gonna be at the ice cream
shop because i just referred them
to the ice cream shop and then you got
the ads that walk you
these little young college kids you know
how much money do you think they make
what are
they getting rich making a [__] movie
you asked them you get high
when the kid came and got me at the
parking garage you get hot dog yeah i do
his inedible thank you
now that working that [__] kid stuck
to me like blue [__]
that [__] he wouldn't let nobody
talk to me get away from him
go away he had an umbrella it started
raining he put an umbrella over me i'm
like what the [__]
he goes man you're a great guy thank you
for helping me out
i haven't had we like that because they
smoked it they went and [__] got high
by the time i was shooting 10 people
already
i'm like this is this is my type of day
some girl came up to me afterwards she's
like thank you for blessing the set
today
right you were [__] great you were
you know and i was i was excited
i was excited to [__] work i was
excited that's a [__] movie guys
i'm a bum i'm a bum this is why i tell
you
if i could do this [__] any if you could
fog up a [__] glass
the other day somebody came to me my
daughter's best friend's mom was like
they're offering
a podcasting course at like a college
around here
she goes why don't you go teach it i'm
like who would take a podcasting course
do you know what i'm saying like
probably a lot of people for three
credits you can just go on youtube
everyone
i know i know i know i don't know what
the [__] i was talking about but anyway
the set got nice and lit and it was just
a blast
it was really a blast
you know man i i got to tell you
something guys and
and i don't i've become a good little
[__] actor in the last couple years
you know i play myself i'm just
i don't know what the [__] i do you know
i hate watching myself i will never
watch myself as soon as i come on i
can't [__] hear my voice but from
time to time sometimes i go let me just
look at like i watched
the first marion i did i think that's
the best work i've ever done in my life
i really do i think the marin let me go
crazy
got kudos to him he was like do what you
do dogs so i did what he told me to
[__] do
and it was great you know when i first
got to l.a nobody talked to me as a
comic nobody talked to me
even though i was at the store rogan
talked to me ari talked to me duncan
talked to me
but nobody else wanted nothing to do
with me i was at the store ripping it up
but nobody would talk to me you know
what that felt like it felt [__]
pretty
shitty everybody was going to montreal
agents were signing everybody
nobody was talking to me meanwhile i'm
at the store at a [__] 12 30
following paul mooney
[__] throwing heat every [__]
night just getting better stronger
and then when they would put me into the
regular shows and there was a fallout
and i would go 10 30.
i'd blow that [__] room up nobody
would talk to me that's fine i figured
that i would just keep getting stronger
maybe had to add something to my arsenal
you know when i got to l.a i was a 50
a show feature if you're my agent you
get five dollars
you can't make no money with five
dollars women give you five dollars
fifty dollars
right so they send you out for auditions
now i never [__] acted
what do you think i grew up going to
acting class in new york come on i would
rob acting class i don't know about
[__] acting
you know you learn how to act you you
[__] with credit cards
when i would use like a [__] weird
names credit card like you
you go in like ming ho if i can go with
ming ho's credit card and use it and the
guy looks at you and you
your name is min yeah okay that's
[__] acting
you know i mean i'm just using that that
used to be a bit i used to do because it
was true
if you could [__] use a stolen credit
card
with a an asian guy's name on it
you could [__] act as dumb as that
[__] sounds
so i took a couple acting classes i
didn't go
into it blind i took a couple acting
classes i didn't want to be a [__]
[__]
you know i had already blown off the
pilot and i had already
embarrassed myself in basketball i
wanted to know what i was doing so i
went and i took a formalized acting
class
i didn't make it my life i didn't go out
at night
you know i got to go home and rehearse
my scene from the godfather [__] those
people you're going to go
you know you get people that take that
[__] really [__] serious i rehearsed
and i
did the things and i went to the cold
reading workshops
you know i did what i had to do just to
get by
i didn't submerge myself into it you
know i figured that the more i do it
the bet the better i get and i had a
great manager at the time that was
sending me out and i was building my
resume
you know if you look at my mdb guys it's
tremendous
i got tons of [__] on there
so now i'm in a position that i don't
really know what i want to do
but i might as well [__] act while
i'm here i would
i mean my dream guys my dream
would be to be on law and order
recurring that would be my [__] dream
i mean
blue bloods is going on this is the last
season so
i missed out on that that's a great
[__] show it became
a [__] great show for 20 years cbs
couldn't put together a show 10 o'clock
on friday nights
i remember years ago they were
struggling on friday nights first they
had a show with
joe pantliano on and that bombed
and then they had a show with uh
lo rob lowe and that bomb and then you
know what they did
they put a show with joe pants and rob
lowe together and then that bombed on
cbs
nobody remembers that one check it out
you'll see
[Music]
lying to you rob lowe's show was on nbc
that bombed the tent
yeah joe pancho was on cbs that bombed
the 10.
so they put them together and then they
put them together on cbs
and they still bombed at 10 o'clock
should have went to abc so
[__] maybe abc had tim allen
see everybody's trying to get that
friday night show always remember when
you watch tv
some network's like [__] we're gonna
lose friday anyway why
try it no there's people that stay home
yeah there's tons of people that stay
home so you got to try to win friday
night so that's why tim
allen the last show i think man standing
i'm not sure
something was on friday night they're
always looking for something for friday
night that
and blue bloods was great nbc this year
decided to [__] shoot
you know they have law and order
organized crime which
that's the one i'm going for but they're
not looking for mugs like mine they're
looking for a little bit
more americanized faces so people don't
get their feelings hurt
so what i'm thinking of doing is law and
order picked up like four [__] shows
this year
they did like law and order [__] if
you abort some
kid law and all the helicopters law and
order [__]
uh da's office they're doing like four
pilots check it out i'm not lying to you
so
i would love to get recurring on lawn
oil that's my [__] dream
to be a a detective something like that
so
who the [__] knows i i acted last week
it was great i'm gonna keep putting
auditions
on tape and uh i put about
six of them on tape but because of my
focus uh issues i cannot remember the
lines guys
this is how bad i was a month two months
ago three months ago
now i'm starting to read now i'm
starting to read that rob haufen book
again
i was starting to read the jimmy page
book i was up to the part where
he just joined his first band so it was
really
the interesting jimmy page book
interesting
i did not know this and
i knew this but i didn't know this for
you [__] music buffs
they were all influenced by one
song because of one song
the stones the beatles
and jimmy page got into music
the king of rock elvis presley
i forget the name of the song no one
whatever
something no room for candy something
like that
jimmy page picked up the guitar after he
heard that song
keith richards picked up the guitar
after you heard that song
and there's somebody else that credits
that song
and it kills me today that we don't see
more elvis on tv
i grew up on elvis i [__] loved elvis
growing up
since i thought he was great dog i saw a
picture of us about two months ago
listen i'm not gay but i give props you
know what i'm saying
i'm not gay but i give props i know when
a man is [__]
really good looking brad pitt is a good
looking [__] how do i know
i watch moneyball three times this week
i love [__] brad pitt okay
i'm a brad pitt [__] i'll stab a
[__] for brad pitt
but that dude is a good looking [__]
dude what are we talking about
elvis elvis dog elvis presley
i saw a picture him about a month ago i
called my wife i go
i've never seen a prettier man's face in
this guy right there he
you have no idea how much i love dalvis
as a kid
jailhouse rock that's my jam do you
understand me that jailhouse rock
that movie that whole [__] thing i
was
i remember [__] when we were kids
there was the abc
after school movie every day 4 30 and
they used to have gidget week
[__] elvis week elvis goes to hawaii
you know
[__] jailhouse rock i haven't watched
one of those movies in 20 [__] years
nobody talks about all this no more it's
like oh this doesn't [__] exist
quincy jones just uh was talking about
him was he
apparently he was a little racist a
little while racist
yes yes elvis was
i'm not sure he was racist i i i have a
problem with that
you know i have a problem with that
you know elvis was a hero the most but
he never meant [__] to me he was
straight up racist the sucker was simple
and playing [__] man john wayne
cuz i'm black and i'm proud
already i'm hyped for some man most of
my
heroes don't appear in those stamps i
you know i heard kind of you know he
robbed the black man you know that's
that's the word
on the [__] street i don't know how
true it is i wasn't there
it was way before my [__] time you
know i don't know
what what was wrong what but i do know
that
in this book i was reading he influenced
it was i forgot the name of the [__]
song
when somebody sees the podcast put it up
on uh
on uh on the [__] comments you know
nobody [__] talks about elvis
how did we get on talking about albus
anyway i loved that song
richards jimmy page that's what i'm
looking up here
it's not pajama pants or nothing like
that no one for [__]
whatever this [__] guy has to come on
monday [__] mornings
can you believe this [__] i'm trying to
[__] do my little podcast in here in
[__] peace
dude they came a couple days ago to my
house broke our window
our whole door window to get in the
house they had to replace our whole
which they shattered it with one of
those things that were flowing out there
with
i came over the podcast i'm like what
the [__] happened to the window
for ain't one thing it's the [__]
other guys but yeah baby let's play
house
yes that's it i mean i think that's it
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's not like if
you listen to the jam
it's a great jam it's not a [__]
sense it's not [__] you know
sad but true but it [__] works you
know
it works for me a little bit but uh
you know you never know who influences
what i've heard different stories about
john wayne being racist
i've heard different stories you know i
read an article let a couple weeks ago
that's why i had a
i didn't know if i was going to put eric
clapton up slow hand i read this article
that people were complaining that
he made remarks in 19 whatever who gives
a [__]
it's weird with art man because i have a
lot of artists that i love their art but
it's like
what were they thinking i don't know
what you know i don't like it i don't
know what
i don't know what i heard that they were
clapping and said some stuff about throw
them out of england this i
don't [__] know i don't know i don't
care you know what i leave it up to the
music i'm the type of guy listen
and this even goes for me okay
this goes for me and this goes for
anybody else and if
you have a problem with this then i
don't know what to tell you
if you listen to what comes out of a
celebrity's mouth
for political if you're banking a
celebrity what he has to say
you know if i like brad pitt but
i don't give a [__] what he's got to say
you know
i honestly you want to honest to god
truth i really don't give a [__] what
he's got to say
look at my boy bruce springsteen he
talks [__]
he got a [__] dui you know
you can't you can't you know these
[__] celebrities sometimes say
[__] you know a couple weeks ago they
they did the academy awards i think i
don't know what they did the grammys i
don't know
don't don't quote me on this but they
[__] it was downtown l.a
the cops surrounded the place for them
so the homeless wouldn't attack them you
know they
defended the place and have these people
going up on stage
talking [__] about the cops you know the
cops defund the police blah blah blah
listen i know we have a police problem
in this country
i saw the video again from glendale the
shoplifter i got beat up by four cops
you know
right now the world's on this [__]
axis you're going to see more and more
of this now whatever this has been going
on for 2 000 years and now is the time
to [__] pick it out
and i understand and i understand that
it's getting rougher
but listen you know i was in new york
friday like i told you
i saw a lot of cops and
i saw a lot of shady little things i saw
something i wasn't going to talk about
on here but i got to talk about it i saw
something that was so [__] disturbing
as i was walking in new york just one
thing
it was the only [__] thing that
only negative that i saw
i saw a beautiful beautiful
asian woman i was walking
and i was about to hit the thing
and there was cars coming
so she was on the corner but on the
street a little bit
and she was i as i was walking towards
the corner
i saw her trying to flag a cat okay she
was like this like with a handout and as
i
i got to the light she was maybe seven
feet from me you know like
she was where the [__] ac dc poster
is okay
but maybe three more feet behind me
and she was facing that way
and i heard a cab driver pull up
i don't know what nationality was i'm
not here to say anything
and he goes you got a better day of
dying than
me picking putting you in this cab you
and me and this little young guy just
looked at each other like
[__] hate is real right there
right there i mean it was right behind
me guys
she was out there waiting i didn't even
think about it i just thought she's
[__] hot she's [__] look at this
this is the real deal here new york is
back [__]
and the cab driver pulled up to her and
he lowered his window
and he's like you gotta it'll be a cold
day in hell
before i pick you [__] up
and he [__] sped away and i actually
like
turned around and i wanted to go up to
her and
ask her if she was all right but in
today's condition
the last thing i needed was for her to
turn around and karate chop me and then
[__]
next thing you know i'm [__] in
trouble i don't know because i know if
if somebody if i was waiting at a
[__] thing if i'm waiting for a
[__] cab and somebody goes hey you
[__]
you know you got a [__] uh it's a
cold day in hell before i
pick up a [__] [__] like you up i'm
gonna be like
what the [__] just happened like i you
know what if you don't want to pick me
up just don't pick me up you just keep
going
just keep going right that's what i
would do i don't want to pick her up i
don't pick him up
i would pick her up because she's
beautiful just to talk to her just to
see where she's from i mean what you
know who's your mother who's your father
i want to
i want to go suck your dad's dick you're
so [__] good-looking that's her old
richard pryor joke don't be [__] uh
saying i stole jokes i just remembered
it you know i just
wanted do you know what i'm saying to
you but for you to stop
lower your window and say that and then
take off
it'll be a cold day now i mean i was
like okay
this is the [__] world today because
he didn't need the fare
yeah i guess he didn't [__] get the
memo i guess he didn't do some [__] but
you know you see this kind of [__] and
this isn't what i'm living through i'm
happy down here i'm okay
i'm getting healthier i'm happier you
know i
i'm not mad at anybody i we're lucky
we're doing a podcast
my daughter's playing [__] softball i
mean
thursday night guys she lost an
eight-inning
game they [__] played their hearts
out
mercy had a great all those girls did
great and they lost at the end by one
run a run scored
the girl got the ball hit to her and she
didn't know whether to throw
the third and she threw it home the
pitch was good but the girl stepped on
the [__] plate
before the game you know before the
thing came and
even the coach cried the game was so
[__] good i had a piss
and i was holding it in because the game
was so good okay
and not a parent [__] moved i had a
piss and finally i waited for mercy to
hit
and i go okay i saw the little lady with
the cart
there's a little cute lady that drives a
little cart there the [__] bathroom
is
[__] three miles away i went earlier
to try to piss
by the [__] car but you can't take
your dick out of the park if not i'll
have to [__] register as a sex
offender
so i was like [__] that i'm not taking
my dick i had no park in new jersey i
ran
over the [__] i got in the cart with
her
and she even told me she goes what is
what's going on over here this is a
great game she goes parents are leaving
the other games
and they're watching this game we had
like 100 people in attendance i mean it
was [__] great
and they said we're going to extend it
to 8 15.
just let him play till 8 15. whatever
happens happens i was excited and all of
a sudden
the bases were loaded and [__]
the run scored and and it was at 8 15.
like right there they held on all the
way to the end
mercy had four hits she pitched she
threw a couple people out she
she caught a pop-up i got to tell you
when i
when you see your daughter cry when you
see your child cry
it's a rough one and i was her
that night i was having i was okay that
night
but it was a long game and
when she came over to me she was bawling
i mean the the team's got 11 girls
nine girls were crying and the [__]
coach was crying
then we went over the coach gave him
more frisbees and wiffle ball bats
we whipped out some [__] cupcakes
and we just hung out and you know
some of the girls were still upset mercy
was fine when she left but then when she
got in the car
she was upset and we had to [__] talk
her off a ledge and tell her that
you did great you made it to the
all-stars you
you made friends i go you know how
all the people that came to your games
your uncle bobby your uncle george
your uncle eddie your aunt lisa they're
not my brothers or sisters
we all grew up together your uncle joe
we all grew up together
and we started this is sports
i met an economist through baseball i
meant you know
half of these shits i go these girls
that you're meeting
that you're playing with you're going to
be friends with them forever you're
going to be talking about this in high
school
you're probably gonna be friends with
them in college and she's got a little
girlfriend
from staten island they moved here [__]
her name is nicole she's got a little
brother named joey i [__] love them
and nicole is a bruiser and so is mercy
and they hang out there and they got
each other's backs
that makes me happier never that makes
me happy she didn't have that in
california
she was hanging out with a bunch of kids
that are allergic to peanuts in
california they couldn't get out of
their own [__] way
didn't know what that gender was that
[__] ain't popping off here
that [__] ain't popping off here you
know what i'm saying these kids are
treated
the two sets of kids we hang out with
it's gotta be eight different [__]
families and there ain't no [__]
nonsense here these are the paydays
these [__] parents are thinking of
pulling their kids out of school and
putting them on catholic school
because they don't want this thing that
they're gonna teach now in the schools
that they're [__] pissed these jersey
catholics the people across the street
from me
the people by jimmy's house they're all
talking about [__] this [__]
no we don't want this [__] in our
[__] world i'm here with some good
[__] people dog
we got there like i said there's no
peanut allergies here in this
neighborhood
there's no identifying i identify with a
rabbit no there's none of that [__]
you know this is straight up
gangsterville we ain't [__] around
here who the [__]
you know what i'm saying i mean it's the
truth
you know i identify with a rabbit you
know you guys heard what's her name
demi lovato she's california sober
listen either you're sober you're
[__] nut i'm not sober i'm smoking
dope
and i'm popping those [__] 25
milligram edibles i'm
at least i'm working on something guys
i'm not smoking all [__] day like i
was
you know i'm down to
272 pounds
that's [__] awesome man when i got
here i was
316 [__] pounds
wow okay from the stress and the [__]
the xanax and whatever the [__] else i
was [__] eating the edibles and
the [__] mexican food and everything
else
and i'm just i just lift weights four
days a week today i didn't lift i had to
take
the [__] uh kickboxing
i didn't lift on saturday because friday
i had to work
and then saturday i was supposed to lift
at 11 but i didn't
but i went to the gym on sunday and like
a little quickie
20 minutes just to [__] because today
is my big lift day
at 11 so that's how i usually [__]
run it but uh
i'm better guys i'm better i'm a lot
better than what i was
uh i we struggled mike knows that
october november these podcasts were
[__] rough
joey was somewhere else but you know
what man i can feel it
and all i could equate it to was loss
i lost something and i finally i
took my own advice and i spoke to
somebody in fact i have another meeting
with her tomorrow night
on zoom and we had a great discussion
you know i'm not gonna sit here and tell
you guys to do something
and then play a a holier-than-thou type
attitude and not do it either
i told you people a couple weeks ago if
you're struggling it's cheap counseling
online
you know i heard that all the good
therapists are booked up because every
you know when when i heard that line
a lot of people are suffering like their
minds aren't right i was like okay
i'm not the only one i'm in with good
company and then renee incarcerone
an old church guy wrote a post a couple
days ago
that he's been struggling i mean he's a
veteran and stuff like that young kid
moved to denver and i sent him a private
note i
said something on facebook like just uh
but then i sent him a private note and i
explained to him
that listen even your uncle joey who's a
[__] savage
had his moments and i had a [__]
talk to somebody and let me tell you
something and made a world of a
difference
for starters i'm the type of guy i use
my friends as therapists
i what were you going to go play 400
what do you got that friend for
you've been friends with him for 30
years he knows you more than ever he
knows you better than you know yourself
probably
but you know what i talked to all my
friends and
they each had a different uh whatever
and i appreciated it but i just wanted
to be right
i talked to her one time and i felt that
much better at least i had a direction
she gave me some homework
and uh it was basically journaling
and it came down to what was really
bothering me
i mean listen man you look at the events
the last year
uh a move a big move cross country
you know new faces new things knee
surgery
pain pills those pain pills those are
six
long [__] weeks and i was keeping it
together for you guys i was trying
[__] hard
but it killed my [__] stomach i had
to wear that watch i had nausea
i was barfing i thank god i threw the
last 13 away
somebody offered me two the other day
they're like hey you still have any pain
i got nope i don't even want them in my
[__] house i'm fine
like if i got pain to leave ice and
[__] bandages
put the [__] cbd line on and i'm good
no more nothing
so it took a while but it took talking
to somebody
i told you a couple weeks ago about the
meetings
listen you know what man i was even
thinking of zooming into a meeting just
to watch
you don't have to talk you could listen
and listen to other people's stories and
sometimes you gain strength just from
listening you don't have to always
[__] talk
you could just listen in these meetings
and see what other people are going
through and go okay
i'm not the only one you know he's a
plumber maybe you relate to him because
he's a plumber you're a plumber
maybe he's a machinist you're a
machinist i don't [__] know
but i had to do what i had to do i don't
know i don't give a [__] there's no
stigma with it
at least i'm mad enough to say i
wouldn't talk to somebody and i feel 150
[__] percent better i'll be a better
father
i'll be a better comic i'll be a better
actor and i'll be a better friend and
then at the end of the day
that's all that matters you know i took
a test
and it looked like i had like a little
mild depression
you know i get up early guys so there's
no laying in bed for me there's no
watching tv with a robe on
that doesn't happen in my world i push
i've always pushed ahead you guys seen
me [__] on twitter in the mornings
saying good morning that's not
pre-fucking programmed
that's uncle joey that's up you know i'm
saying like friday i had to go to work
i didn't know if i was gonna see mercy
that night so guess what i did
i set the alarm for [__] six and i
got up i did my
patreon work and then i [__] mercy
got up and i hung out with her we had
breakfast
i didn't think i would see you friday i
ended up getting home at 8 16
and we watched a little tv and you know
we talked a little bit i
showed her the call sheets and whatever
we had a great time but that's what it's
all about
i'm not i wasn't uh i talked to hari
who had gone through his own thing and
he helped me out
[__] fantastically but it was the
lady i spoke to really put me on the
path and guys
i feel a lot better so expect uh
better things from me funnier podcast
and me going off from time to [__]
time if you're watching this podcast
waiting for me to get high or whatever
listen go get your [__] hat on with
the propeller and take a walk around the
corner let's grow up here you know what
i'm saying
let's grow the [__] up here that's
always pitch somebody told me a couple
of [__] years ago
who was the person i wanted to smoke
with the most and i'm like nobody
i don't want to know about it who do i
want to smoke i don't want to smoke with
nobody
first of all i get a sore throat when i
smoke with people i've always got a sore
throat since i was [__] 13.
and then when ralphie may got that
[__] lung
issue from traveling all across the
country and smoking with different
people when he got the [__] triple
pneumonia
i cut it out for sure i'll give you a
joint to smoke i'll bring you a joint
mike in my life
i'll bring you a [__] joint but i
don't need to build a bond
what am i an indian i don't need to pass
a peace pipe around
there's too many germans and you
[__] are filthy and
you guys get sick and don't tell
somebody you know how many times i've
been to cleveland or [__] columbus
and the guy will smoke with you
and after he smokes you'll go yeah i
just got over
[__] lung infection and you're like
really thank you
thank you give it to me you know the
best ever and we'll end with this
was god rest his soul god rest his soul
i love him i learned to we haven't
talked enough about the piano player
from the school uh store jeff scott jeff
scott was a great guy
23 years i was up there with him and i
loved him and you know
we talked about him a little when he
died a few months ago but
it's given me time to i really had to
mourn him
i really had a process i mean i've been
processing brody
i thought about ralphie the other night
but jeff scott
was a great [__] guy and part of my
stage success at the comedy store was
jeff scott because he would play
different music for me
and i knew how to come out to certain
music and just [__]
we used to do this song do it till
you're satisfied
and i just had it down with him you know
it was just great
but jeff i'll tell you a funny story
about jeff
jeff had you know and he's god now got
arrested so he was a great man i hope
god has taken care of him and stuff
jeff had uh hiv
you know he was hiv for years he had on
the control
when i first met jeff i didn't give a
[__] if he was gay he was great
and every time i saw jeff i hugged him i
mean we were all good friends with jeff
that meant being gay to me this i don't
care
i i hug gay guys harder than i hug
tough guys because they need dog bigger
from me than not you know what i'm
saying like i love gay men
i have no problem with [__] gay men
so what was i talking about
just kind of just got so you know
i love jeff and jeff was a pothead you
know as soon as you got to the store
when we were broke in 98 97
jeff always has something for you jeff
always will call me and ari and go
what are you guys doing you want to go
in the back yeah let's go jeff jeff
wouldn't sit there and watch the
you know he had a 20 minute break in
between all the comics
you know he would play unless you wanted
like this comics that said jeff play the
piano while i'm up there like jeff ross
a lot of guys like jeff [__] around jeff
was great like that he was he was great
he was a musician that became a comedy
musician is that
weird to say i don't know he was he was
a comedy musician
he would do the [__] piano for you
and [__]
but when i first met jeff you know i
loved him right off the bat he was great
me ari all of us were broke so if
somebody asked you if you wanted to
smoke you got a vlogging smoke
right and i remember one night i'm at
the store maybe
four months and we're outside and jeff
comes up and he goes hey what time is
just buying
let's go look we always go look at 12 30
you got time
you want to go get high and i go yeah
jeff and we went to the back
and we're getting high and we we
finished smoking the [__] joint
and also he looks at me and he says
something weird and he goes
yeah i don't feel good the hiv
medication
makes me feel [__] groggy i go what
hiv
and he goes i got hiv i go now you
[__] tell me after you smoking dry
with me
you know i knew i couldn't get hiv from
him but
you know it's just you just miss people
you know
so i don't want somebody else coming up
to me going you know i just had covet
do you know what i'm saying like that's
what i was really scared of like during
that's what really deterred me from the
reefer was covet
period listen your mind
[__] those dudes in houston didn't
write that song
because it's not a topic sometimes your
mind plays tricks on you
okay and i know it happens to you guys
because it happens to me a ton
during covet every time i smoke my lungs
would hurt
and i would go god damn and i got
covered it's your mind it's the good
weed you know i'm a
i'm a comic so your mind is a sense of
humor so your brain has to have some fun
from time to time too right so
your brain tells you [__] like you ever
like
i don't know 10 years ago
i went to pee one day and a little
squirt of blood came out
dog i couldn't run to the doctor quick
enough i [__]
i you know right away you think of
cancer
right away you're thinking all the worse
things you know
i got on the phone with the doctor i got
to see you right away he goes i got like
an opening at 3 30 i'll be there
and i get there and i'm like doc i got
cancer you know what are you talking
about
i peed a little blood he goes before you
[__] go off the [__] deep end here
did anything happen anything happened
the last couple days just think hard
i'm sitting there like okay i go i want
to kick boxing that's right and the girl
need me
on the one nut and he goes let me see it
i took my nuts out for the doctor
dr waxler i showed him and he goes see
this little thing there he just
he goes if you keep bleeding call me
back and then we'll take care
i went home and i never bled out of my
dick again do you understand me but
when you bleed out of your dick you
right away think ah i'm gonna [__]
die i got cancer i got the itchies
anyway i don't [__] even know what
the itchies are
i love you [__] thank you for
sitting with me for an hour on a monday
morning
and talk and [__] i love all this stuff
and i'm back [__]
and i'll be back little by little by
little and then uh
eventually who knows what the [__] will
happen
i want to thank you guys for watching i
want to thank you guys for supporting uh
and i'll see you guys wednesday tip top
[__] magoo
ready to rock thank you again for
watching uncle joey's joint live from
new jersey
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
all right thank you for listening today
you know i love you [__] with
all my heart
i try my best and that's all i could do
for you guys but
the joint is brought to you by one of my
personal favorites i love this company
for what they do
blue chew listen to me blue chew is
fantastic it works quickly
within a half hour you could take out
any time you're asking me joy what's
bluetooth blue chew is an online service
that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis
at a fraction of the cost you could take
at any time
day and night the process is simple sign
up at bluechew.com
and talk to one of our licensed medical
providers once you're approved
which is a matter of minutes you receive
your prescription
within days the best part is it's all
online no visits to the doctor's office
no driving
then you don't have to you know you
gotta can you imagine you have like a
female doctor you gotta tell your heart
your dick's not working how embarrassing
is that
and then you go to the pharmacy and it's
a female pharmacist and she gives it to
you and she looks at you like look at
this [__] mutt
yeah this ships right to your door in a
discrete package not even your mailman
knows nobody knows
nothing this doesn't mean that you have
a defective [__]
unit what i'm giving you is firepower
you understand me so when you do go over
there
you want women to leave your house going
jesus christ just what what what
happened to me
this guy's a [__] savage that's what
bluetooth would do
for you sir if you could benefit from an
extra confidence when it's time to
[__] get down
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for you today
right now go to bluetooth b-l-u-e
capital c-h-e-w free
with promo code joey just pay five hours
for the shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code joey to
receive your first month free
and as always i want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the podcast but listen to
me
blue chew is no joke they're very good
and this deal
you can't knock it down free give it a
shot all you got to do is pay five
dollars for shipping
and you receive your first month for
free all right guys
listen i want to thank bluechu i want to
thank
lucy.com but most importantly i want to
thank you guys
for always having our back and for uh
[__] supporting the podcast and
listening i love you guys with all my
heart have a great [__] monday
stay black and i'll see you
[__] wednesday
tip top [__] magoo
[Music]
foreign